dégainer les emplois du temps un deux
trois mois alexa et voici ma meilleure
amie quatre ans s'apprête à rentrer au
lycée puis croix pattée d'entre eux j'y
crois pas c'est d'entre eux je souhaite
que ce ne sera pas tout à fait ce à quoi
on s'attendait
pourquoi tu m'a rien dit dès que les
cours commenceront au lieu de me voir
moi tout le monde vers alcan c'est
hashtag là pour toi tout le monde
parlera de l'appliquer à un concert
riche beau beaucoup nuxe ici n'était pas
la seule à faire remarquer au calme que
dj compris c'est la meilleure amie tout
béton suis surexcitée par la rentrée
mais j'arrive pas à savoir ce dont j'ai
le plus apte les événements les matchs
de foot
la sélection battait droit
[Musique]
on ferait mieux de rentrer maintenant je
suis le médecin m'interdisais d'aller au
lycée ça va aller oh je parlais à mes
cheveux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une uniformité toi tu es une fille c'est
courageuse maman tu peux pleurer deux
fois par semaine maximum n'expose pas le
quota d'un coup il faut qu on fait ça on
n'a qu'à faire un truc interdite en fait
je pensais plutôt manger une glace
il ya certains moments dans la vie où on
a besoin d'une amie plus que jamais et
parfois on a même mieux qu'une amie on a
une cathy alors maintenant je vais aller
voir comment ça se passe à l'italie
[Musique]